c'est quand j'ai toujours comme ça j'ai
je t'aime je te dois fermer le
périphérique ne porte le cuir en course
car parle dernière pige au huitième jour
de tournage j'avais une soeur aînée mis
dans les pattes et en fait j'aime c'est
crucial à jouer et je pense que c'est
mon seul cas c'était cool d'aller à
skyrock
seulement ça en présentant certaines
accomplissement pour un rappeur de
tricks en plus impressionnant je pense
que perry fleury fait rêver puisque j'ai
découvert un truc que je connaissais pas
vu que j'ai pas été en prison j'espère
pas encore
periph pareil on a marché sur le père y
était bloquée on monte sur la scène du
zénith avec un micro qui ne fonctionne
pas et sans un sou
ma vie en survêt l'été au moment où on
répète ou en fait ils parlent de
salvatore esposito
il me parle de la complexité de ce
personnage et il m'expliquer pourquoi
c'est important que les gens voient mes
faiblesses et je me rappelle la répète
d'après je suis revenu et j'ai regardé
j'ai regardé comment rentrer temps doux
et c'était totalement différent je pense
qu'il pourra vous confirmez c'était
vraiment un beau souvenir le jour où il
m'a annoncé que j'étais pris dans la
série c'est un des meilleurs moments si
ce n'est le plus beau de ma vie on va
dire parce que je suis pas mariée je
pars en fait je me rappelle c'est le
ramadan donc je suis inquiète dormir et
du coup ils savaient que je la remets et
venez écouter les doigts dans le nez
pendant que je dormais tu vois c'est
celle où il ya midi égard moi j'y crois
pas trop à l'histoire de format string
c'est simple et c'est mauvais et je suis
là j'écoute la conversation est comme un
conte à la fin j l c'est quoi sa ferme à
strip cette discussion là c'est là celle
qu'on a le plus répété en casting ans
répète je crois que cette séquence là
dans 20 ans je me rappellerai encore
[Musique]
tout
c'est tout